okay but 2016 is almost over in fact
today is the last day that I am hosting
a new show in 2017 Monday December 26th
I'm sorry in 2016 until 2017 Monday
December 26th of 2016 host of the
Benjamin Dixon show Ben Dixon will be
filling in for me with david pakman show
producer pat and then we will be off for
the rest of the year but i do want to
talk about a few different things that
are going to be going on number one uh
the last uh the end of 2016 we are going
to be counting down the top 5 most
viewed and listened two episodes of the
david pakman show from 2016 so if you're
watching on free speech TV if you're
watching on our TV affiliates you can
expect sort of new shows and that will
be doing a new introductions and
counting down some of these most popular
episodes of 2016 we will then resume
with totally new programming on Tuesday
January third of 2017 bendixen Monday
thank you for a record year I've said it
before and I will say it again we have
set subsequent monthly records across
all platforms throughout much of this
year November and December included and
most importantly 2016 as a whole was our
best year ever this includes YouTube
subscribers now nearing 300,000 this
includes total youtube views this
includes podcast downloads we now have
more radio and TV affiliates up close to
200 at this point then we have ever had
before more new paid subscribers during
2016 than we have ever seen before I
only have you to thank this show started
very meager Lee in the basement of a
community radio station in Northampton
Massachusetts called WX oj Valley free
radio it was one show every two weeks
that's it because of your support it
grew to once a week then it grew to
twice a week then it grew to four times
a week and a
full of years ago expanding to what may
be its final form as as some of our more
religious viewers might like to say a
five shows a week a real daily
independent progressive analysis and
news program and it's all because of you
so to close the year out if you have not
signed up for membership please do this
is why we exist if 26c to 2017 rather
ends up being another record year it
will no doubt be because of the
continued growth of the David Pakman
show membership program so go to david
pakman.com slash membership if the
normal prices are too expensive use the
coupon code I voted 17 we have great
member benefits including a members-only
bonus show every day we do an extra show
just for our paid subscribers as a
thank-you because you really are the
drivers of support for our program we
also were doing a major crowdfunding
campaign because my goal for the show
for 2017 is we go beyond just
progressive media we go to progressive
activism and progressive engagement and
progressive coordination and that is one
of the goals we are raising money for at
david pakman.com slash donate anything
you can donate i don't care if it's a
dollar or a hundred dollars or a
thousand dollars or maybe fifteen
thousand dollars which is that top perk
that is available anything you can
donate helps our cause thanks to
everybody for a great 2016 we are going
to take phone calls today for the last
time we are going to answer some really
great and somewhat funny audience
questions for the last time today thanks
to everybody send me your end of your
thoughts about the show and what we
should be doing in 2017 on twitter i'm
on twitter at d pakman and i look
forward to talking to everybody in the
new year but that's not it for today
let's take phone calls after the break